ننتقل بكم مباشره الى كلمه للرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان
7.6 لدينا خسائر كبيره جدا
جديار كبير جدا في العشر مدن التي تاثرت
من هذا الزلزال او هذين الزلزلين
الاول زرت مدينه كهرمان مرش واضنوهاتاي
زياره وفي طبعا اتفقت الوضع هناك وشخص
الحاله التي يعيشها الناس ويوم امس في
غازي عنتاب واسمانيا
وايضا
صرت المنطقه وشخصت الاضرار فيها وزاره
المتضررين من هذه الزلازل واليوم وهنا نحن
في اضيان وبعد قليل الى مدينه مالاتيا
المدينه اتمنى الشفاء لجرحانه
واعزي تعريفه
كلمه
هذا الزلزال اعرف انا لا كلمات تعبر عن
حاله عن حزننا هنا
الى
18,991 وعدد المصابين
وصل الى
75,570 شخص تقريبا
اجلاء المواطنين
بالخروج من هذه المدن الى المدن
المجاوره
حوالي 1900 مبنى هنا في هذه المدينه
ان مقام الذين اتوفو جراء هذه
الشهاده ونحن نعتقد انهم شهداء باذنه
تعالى
اود ان اؤكد لاقارب
المتوفيين
اننا سنساعدكم في كل شيء
وطبعا المتضررين هنا عليهم الا يقلقوا
ابدا
سنعيد اعمار هذه المدينه بكل الطرق وفي
اقصر وقتا ممكن
ارى هنا
في هذه المناطق في كل المنطقه في العشر
مدن ونقدم المساعدات ونكرس كل
الامكانياتنا وامكانيات الدوله لتقديم
المساعدات طبعا
مناطق زلزال المتضرره
تقع في منطقه واسعه جدا طبعا تبلغ هذه
المساحه حوالي 500
التوجه الى هذه المنطقه والتدخل في كل
منطقه ربما يصعب علينا
ولذلك انا اتخذ بعض سنعاني بعض الصعوبه في
هذا الامر وطبعا المانع الاخر هو عوامل
الجو وظروف الصعبه والظروف الشتويه الصعبه
هناك
صعوبات بسبب الطقس وبسبب دمار في بعض
الطرق وايضا بسبب ازدحام في الطرق بسبب
السيارات المتوجهه الى المدينه ومن
المدينه طبعا اتحدث عن العشر مدن
المتاثره من هذه الزلازل ولكن
امكانيات الممكنه في هذه الى هذه المنطقه
كل الامكانيات الدوله تتواجد هنا الان
ونقدم كل المساعدات الممكنه وكل مؤسسات
الدوله الان تعمل من اجل
المنقوبه كما تعلمون اتخذنا قرار اعلان
حاله الطوارئ في الطوارئ في العشر مدن
ولكن علي ان اذكر هذه النقطه مع الاسف
هناك بعض الناس الذين
يهاجمون الاسواق والمحال التجاريه ويسرقون
منها السلع ويذهبون هذه السلع والبعض
يحاول سرقه هذه
المستلزمات والمواد والسلع الان الدوله
اتخذت هذه التدابير والان الخطوات ستكون
اكثر عنفا مع هؤلاء الذين يهاجمون ويسرقون
وطبعا سيتم فورا معاقبه هؤلاء باشد الطرق
ربما بعض الصعوبات وبعض النقص الذي عانينا
منه في هذه الفتره ولكن الدوله ومؤسساتها
تتواجد هنا
وتقدم كل المساعدات للمحتاجين
وزير المواصلات السيد عادل رئيس توجه فورا
الى هذه المدينه
ميمت مش الوزير بعد ان انهى عمليه البحث
والانقاذ وتنسيق عمليات البحث والانقاذ
جاء فورا الى هذه المدينه
وساعد وزير المواصلات الذي يتواجد هنا
وكان
عمليات البحث والانقاذ وتقديم المساعدات
وطبعا تم تعيين بعض الولاد من المدن
الاخرى وبعض من المدن الاخرى الاولويه هي
انقاذ الانسان وانقاذ الارواح
استثمارات ثانيه وهذه كانت الاولويه منذ
اللحظات الاولى
لحدوث هذا الزلزال ولا احد يمكنه ان يستغل
او ان يحاسب هذا الامر
باننا استطعنا ان نركض لانقاذ كل الارواح
ولنسعى لانقاذ كل الارواح في العشر المدن
المنكوبه الى حد الان تستمر عمليات البحث
والانقاذ مع فرق الانقاذ التي جاءتنا من
الدول الاخرى وهناك عرض 44 دوله لتقديم
مساعداتهم والى حد الان تستمر الفرق
بالتوجه الى هذه المنطقه من عدد كبير من
الدول ولان الدمار كان قد
اثر على منطقه كبيره جدا وهناك
التي تتالف من 141 الفرد
الى حد الان جمعنا اكبر عدد ممكن ربما هذا
الفريق الذي يعمل هنا هو اكبر فريق
يعمل في منطقه منكوبه حول العالم ولكن الى
حد الان هناك مناطق لم نتمكن من الوصول
الى تقديم مساعدتها اعتذر نحن نعلم ان
الوضع صعب جدا ولكن الدوله التركيه تحاول
وتسعى بكل جهودها ومع كل المنظمات ومع كل
الفرق ان تصل الى الكل هذه المناطق وتقدم
المساعده نحن نتفهم ونعرف جيدا ان الجميع
سعر يتفهم هذه الحاله هناك تحديات كبيره
جدا نعاني منها خلال تقديم هذه المساعدات
وابرزها شروط
ايضا اتساع الرقعه الجغرافيه هنا في مدينه
كلس وفي مدينه
عمليات البحث والانقاذ والان يتم رفع
الانقاذ منها بشكل كامل ويتم العمل على
اعاده العمار على تقديم كل المساعدات
الممكن سنستمر بعمليه الانقاذ الى ان نخرج
اخر
مواطن عالق تحت هذه على هذه النقطه اننا
نعيد اعمار هذه المدينه والمدن التسعه
الاخرى من خلال مشاريعنا الجديده
ونار
نقدم ايضا المعونات الماليه
بمقدار 10 الاف ليره تركيه لكل اسره
ومواطنين الذين لا يرغبون بالبقاء في هذه
المخيمات سندفع لهم اجور
المنازل بشكل يعني سندفع ايجار المنازل
وسار ايجار المنزل
اخرى عفوا بيوت اخرى ومنازل اخرى في مدينه
كما اننا سنسعى لمساعدتهم وتقديم المعونه
الماليه لهم بدفع اجور اجار المنازل لمده
عام واحد في المدن الاخرى في هذه الفتره
سنكون قد اكملنا اعاده الاعمار في هذه
المدن ونسلم المنازل لاهاليها في كل
المتطوعين وفرق الانقاذ
ونرى كل الشباب المتطوعين الذين يقدمون كل
المساعدات الممكنه
ويساهمنا في عمليه البحث والانقاذ الى حد
الان تستمر
ونحن نرى
قوه هذا الشعب ومتانه هذا الشعب هذا الشعب
هو الشعب يتولد وشعب يثق بقوه الله يثق
بايمان انه سيستغل
كان دائما يثق بحكومته
قد وجانا هذه الصعوبات في نظام
وحتى
مع الاسف
الى الجانب
شعبنا والى جانب اخواننا وبالتالي نحن
لاصحابها والان ايضا
بدانا بالاستعدادات
الوزراء المعنيين وايضا وزاره
الان يعمل
من اجل البدء في اقترب ممكن على ازاله
الانقاض وايضا بدايه الاعمال
في هذه الاثناء
الفنادق في المدن المختلفه
وسنتمكن
من ارسال المواطنين الذين يرغبون بالتوجه
الى هذه الفنادق والسكن هناك لهم كل الطرق
وايضا سندفع كل الاجور الممكنه هناك منهم
سيصادفون
المواطنين بشكل مجاني ايضا الخطوط الجويه
التركيه
امنت رحله جويه مجانيه اؤكد على هذه
النقطه الرحلات الجويه مجانيه
لايصال المواطنين المتضررين من الزلازل
الى المدن السليمه الاخرى لدينا مطابخ
مؤقته متحركه لدينا ايضا
مشافي
الميدانيه لدينا الكثير من الامكانيات
التي نقدمها الان الى ان الجن من هذه
الزلازل
الفرق الدفاع المدني الجميع لديه دور فعال
الان في تامين هذه المناطق والمشاركه ايضا
في عمليات البحث كل فرق الامن
والقوات القوات المسلحه التركيه
يستخدمونها
ومروحياتهم والاتهم الخاصه بالبناء وانقاذ
وكل
هذه
الالات والسيارات والمركبات كلهم يتواجد
هنا الان ليقدموا المساعدات
ان اي شخصيه سياسيه اي مؤسسه
اخرى تنشر كذيب على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي او تحاول
حتى في الاعلام عليكم الا تصدقهم ارجوكم
لا تصدقوهم هذا
الوقت والمكان المناسبين باذن الله تعالى
كل عمليات
المساعدات
نرجو منكم ان تتواصلوا مع اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه والهلال الاحمر
المسؤولين عن توزيع هذه المساعدات وبعد
ذلك يمكنكم ارسال
مساعدات الاهم هنا التقديم المساعدات
بالتنسيق لان ارسال الشاحنات والمساعدات
قبل تنسيق او من دون تنسيق لا يعد بنا فعل
احد من المهم توفير الامكانيه اللوجستيه
لتوزيع هذه المساعدات هناك احتياجات
ستستمر ربما لاشهر طويله جدا لذلك نحتاج
الى فعاليه مساعدات طويله الامد ستساعد
الجميع في الفتره المقبله من الضروري ايضا
ان تكون عمليه المساعدات
تصل الى هذه المنطقه عن طريق افاد اي
اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه رجال
الاعمال والتجار والطلاب وكل
شيء
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه يتم انفاق كل
الليره منها ليره تركيه منها الى
اعاده اعمار هذه المدن والى تقديم
المساعدات اللازمه الى هذه
هؤلاء المتضررين من هذه الزلازل ونحتاج
دعم العالم ايضا لاعاده الاعمار في اقصى
وقت ممكن بالاضافه الى التقديم كل
المساعدات الممكن
نؤكد من هنا ان الجميع الدوله التركيه
والحكومه التركيه مواطنين وشعبها هذه
المدن في
عند
الشعوب في الزلازل الاخرى وفي السيول
والفيضانات في كل شيء استطعنا الجروح في
اكثر
هنا ايضا سنكون قادرين على اعاده اعمار
هذه المدن في هذا الاطار
ان شاء الله
سنقدم الدعم المالي للمتضررين من هذه
الزلازل من المدفوعات الخاصه الطارئه
نستعد ايضا لرفع هذه
الميزه التي ستقدم الى الاهالي المتضرره
من عشر الاف الى 15 الف وايضا سنقدم الدعم
المالي لدفع الايجارات المنزليه في هذه
المدن والذين يرغبون بالتوجه الى مدن اخرى
من لا تشبه لك
تقديم هذه المساعدات الى جانبي الشعبي
ايضا
جهود الانقاذ والبحث والان تطور برامج
حديثه
وشامله لانقاذ المواطنين وتقديم المساعدات
هذه المنطقه ماديا وليذهب ويسرقوا السلع
منها
نقضي على ذلك كما اننا سنقضي على الشخصيات
التي تستغل هذه الفرصه سياسيا ومحاسبهم
جميعا
لحدوث هذه الزلازل وقف الى جانبنا الكثير
من المنظمات القوات المسلحه وفرق الانقاذ
والطوارئ هو المتطوعين والفرق المدنيه
ومنظمات التابعه للحكومه وايضا المنظمات
المدنيه والجميع نشكر كل من وقف الى جانب
الشعب التركي في هذه المح